nos invités bruno dref qui met de
conférences à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
spécialiste de l'europe médiane bonsoir
à vous bruno kreisky merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés yves pozzo di borgo
président de l'institut lecanu et ancien
sénateur udi de paris bonsoir à vous
également et enfin théo lobry
journaliste indépendant spécialiste des
états unis bonsoir à tous les trois
merci d'être avec nous il faut 12 au di
borgo
comment vous avez ressenti ces deux
rencontres cette rencontre bilatérale
inédite
on veut la lumière qui nous a dit d'un
côté une rencontre positive joe biden
tonalité positive également vous l'avez
ressenti vous aussi bon je trouve que ce
qui s'est passé est quelque chose de
très important et je trouve que ça a été
une journée très positifs pour l'europe
et pour la russie et pour l'amérique
alors évidemment justement ce un peu à
faire du bourg en disant ça va obliger
que nos amis de l'union européenne qui
fait du zèle antirusse un peu à corriger
leurs tirs parce qu'ils étaient toujours
suivre les américains c'est juste un peu
d'humour mais je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de le dire par contre je crois qu'il
faut derrière cette séquence biden en
europe c'est-à-dire d'abord le g7
ensuite l'otan ensuite l'union
européenne et en suisse est à rencontre
biden
poutine je crois qu'il faut vraiment ne
pas être naïf et voir qu'il ya une
grande inquiétude des américains face à
la chine la vieille thèse brénaz qui
vous savez qu'ils considèrent que le
prochain conflit mondial afin civile
c'était le conseiller de carter qui
considère que le prochain le veut le
grand débat entre les deux puissances
mondiales sera le débat entre la chine
et les états unis et je crois que les
états unis avec cette séquence vite n
sans rentrer dans ce débat
voilà c'est à dire qu'ils ont vraiment
ils ont d'abord compris qu'il fallait
entraîné les européens notamment le cas
de l'otan sur le temps c'est atlantiste
et l'aller 0-2 et des américains biden
veut sortir le temps du cac d'atlantis
deuxièmement ils valent également s'ils
voulaient ils sont des comptes que la
avec les sanctions la politique un peu
stupide qui avait été menée de la part
des états unis à l'égard d'aidé
européenne si elle est gardée de la
russie que la russie allait dans les
bras de la chine et on a bien vu que
cette rencontre aujourd'hui est un petit
peu pour directement on va continuer à
faire autant de bêtises et je crois que
la chose importante de cette séquence
qui n'est pas uniquement leur inconduite
m.poutine
cette séquence du voyage de biden aux
oraux en europe c'est ça c'est à dire
que se profilent cette grande bataille
je passerai 10 sera j'espère sera pas
une guerre mais cette grande bataille du
savoir qui sera qui aura le contrôle
mondial du monde qui sera la puissance
globale il faut savoir que les chinois
attendent ils considèrent qu'on dit en
2045 qui sera la grande puissance
globale et que les états unis sur la
grande puissance globale ils se rendent
compte qu'ils sont concurrencés par la
chine
je rajouterais une chose aussi c'est
qu'il ya derrière tout ça pour être
démographique vous avez d'un côté les
occidentaux
un milliard de personnes se dire en
présidant unis l'europe et la russie et
de l'autre vous avez la chine avec le
monde entier que presque 7 milliards de
personnes
je dis ça parce que j'étais moi
parlementaire à l'assemblée
parlementaire 2 mondial est ma dernière
réunion comme parlementaire c'était à
dacca au bangladesh
c'était en 2002 en 2017 j'ai bien vu
cette coupure entre d'un côté les
occidentaux dans laquelle il ya les
américains les européens et puis les
russes mais qui est hésitant et qui
jouait plutôt avec l'asie centrale
d'autre côté le reste du monde qui ne
supportent plus les occidentaux je crois
que derrière tout ça cette séquence
biden en europe veut montrer que le
prochain combat j'espère sa par get sa
sera des combats économies sur des
combats de débats ce sera des combats
également de contrôle de la delà des
opinions publiques
ça sera la chine contre la résistance
unis qui sera là comme puissance
mondiale
non bref kia on vient de l'entente mois
par la bouche de notre reporter avait
des fautes in qui ne cherche pas une
guerre froide avec les états unis nous
non plus a répondu joe biden on savait
que les relations entre les deux pays
était au plus bas avant aujourd'hui est
ce que clairement il ya un avant et un
après cette rencontre aujourd'hui sans
doute alors elle était au plus bas donc
elle pouvait difficilement descendre
plus bas si ce n'est qu' on allait vers
une guerre ce qui évidemment on était le
souhaitent personnes et donc on peut
dire que aujourd'hui on a stabilisé les
choses et que donc maintenant le les
relations sont à un niveau disons ou la
sécurité globale semble devoir être
garanti les les négociations reprennent
les ambassadeurs s'échangent et le
l'equilibre désarmement va être sans
doute travailler dans les dents les dans
les mois qui suivent
en revanche évidemment on ne pouvait pas
s'attendre à des miracles c'est à dire
que la situation entre la russie et les
etats-unis et plus largement la russie
et les pays occidentaux sont descendus
tellement bas que il s'agissait donc de
restaurer si je puis dire une confiance
minimum mais évidemment on est loin de
d'aller vers ce qu'on aurait pu appeler
une détente
parce que ça ne peut pas se faire en un
jour et puis effectivement nous sommes
dans un monde multipolaire et
aujourd'hui la russie est bien sûr
important dans ce monde d'autres
puissances émergentes le sont aussi et
est fondamentalement la question
centrale c'est effectivement le rapport
entre la chine et les états unis et dans
ce contexte là les russes ont bien prévu
avant les événements qu'il n'allait pas
rompre avec la chine pour se rapprocher
de l'occident mais en même temps il
voulait stabiliser les rapports avec
l'occident était au low briano nos deux
invités uns parlent tous de la chine est
effectivement qui était manifestement
sur toutes les lèvres surtout en
coulisses son offre comme on dit dans le
jargon des des journalistes mais ni l'un
ni l'autre n'a parlé officiellement en
tout cas de la chine lors des deux
conférences de presse toute façon je moi
je pense personnellement que ce sommet
c'était avant tout un sommet pour
l'image que finalement peu de choses
concrètes en sont sortis si ce n'est le
retour d ambassadeur américain en russie
russo était cependant je pense
qu'effectivement la chine est dans
toutes les têtes et la russie n'est pas
vraiment une
une priorité pour les états unis puisque
la russie ne menace pas le leadership
américain et c'est d'ailleurs l'élément
central du voyage de joe biden en europe
c'est de rétablir le leadership
américain qu'il estime avoir été
souillées entre guillemets par donald
trump durant son mandat
je crois que de ce côté là joe biden a
réussi que ce soit au g7 à l'otan et
cette rencontre même si on n'en tire pas
grand chose
aura au moins permis ou deux hommes de
se rencontrer ils s'étaient déjà
rencontrés mais à l'époque joe biden
était vice président des états unis donc
n'avait pas les mêmes eux mêmes
fonctions disons et des lignes ont très
certainement été tracée entre les deux
pays pour qu' il n'y ait pas de montée
des tensions dans les années où les mois
qui viennent yves pozzo di borgo une
rencontre est peut-être servi à rien
mais non pas une chanson un
infléchissement depuis l'époque
obama ou o'bama traiter la russie de
deux puissances régionales on s'en
souvient là on parle quand même sur un
même pied d'égalité ce qu'à dieu quand
même rassuré des dix meilleures poutines
oui c'est tout c'est vrai que la russie
aux dépens de la russie notamment près
des années 2000 enfin après année alcide
son problème c'est poutine qui l'avait
privé c'était d'apparaître aussi comme
un partenaire des états unis ont
souhaité une grande puissance
l'union soviétique et c'est vrai que
c'était tous leurs problèmes
l'affaiblissement des états unis
dépendant de la russie soit le signer
c'était tout le travail qu'a fait
poutine mais je pense que s'ils
voulaient le les dents je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui plus bp le jeune homme
là qui parle et je veux dire jeune homme
pendant chez areva est tt a raison de le
dire mais je crois que c'était quand
même aujourd'hui quelque chose de qui va
être très important pour la suite mais
très important pour la suite
il ya un état d'esprit qui s'est créé
les problèmes ne sont pas réglés
tout à fait d'accord je confort ce que
dit monsieur le président le poster de
l'inalco mais je crois qu'il y avait un
esprit qui serrés qui s'est imposée et
qui va d'après moi aussi reggae l'union
européenne parce que l'union européenne
c'est un petit peu le petit roquet
contre contre la russie accompagnant un
petit peu ce que les états unis là je
crois qu'il va y avoir un changement
d'attitude là je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important mais moi je continue à
penser que cette affaire de chine et
vous l'avez soulever puis le professeur
d'une halle qu est l affaire la plus
importante
on le voit d'ailleurs très bien parce
que le président chinois alors tout ça
évidemment pas confidentiel mais c'est
pas dans la presse mais le président
chinois à chaque fois qu'il voit un
responsable européen
qu'est ce qui dit il dit mais pourquoi
vous êtes toujours avec les américains a
passé des accords avec nous
bien vu d'ailleurs à l'otan qu est ce qu
a réagi hier je pense que le poste d'un
maquereau est sensible à cet argument il
sait très bien qu'ils n'ont pas changé
mais le président ma croix dans l'otan
il a bien quand même dit les choses
il a dit attendez l'otan c'est
attentiste l'otan ce n'est pas pour le
monde entier et c'est là où on voit très
bien qu'il ya une offensive notamment de
2 des américains avec leur secrétaire
général a fait de l'otan qui était qui
et akata l'europe qui cherche à mener
l'otan à être si vous voulez la grande
puissance militaire contre la chine
alors derrière tout ça aussi il faut je
passe devant le professeur d'alto qu'il
maîtrise mieux que moi ce genre de chose
il faut savoir que parce que les
américains ont la puissance militaire
ils ont si la puissance du dollar et
c'est vrai que si la puissance militaire
s'affaiblit hyper de dollars et que dans
la grande bagarre qui s'annonce entre la
chine et les états unis
il ya aussi la bagarre de celui qu'elle
sera la monnaie mondiale est ce que ça
sera toujours dollars ce qui permet
d'ailleurs aux états unis de tous les
jours de faire fonctionner la planche à
billets est ce qu'un truc complètement
fou et la question qui se pose
maintenant c est ce que la chine va
réussir dans quelques années à imposer
notre monnaie et donc la casse et la
puissance américaine
je crois si ce débat qui sont en germe
dans tout cela mais ce que je retiens
moi c'est que vraiment c'était très
positif
cette rencontre et que je crois que
aussi bien pour l'union européenne que
pour tout le monde fait tout le monde
occidental c'est quelque chose de
positif et bruno 13 ski olivier vient
d'en parler avec son invité un le seul
acteur vraiment concret de la journée
mais comme c'est souvent le cas l'an ii
se rangeant de rencontres bilatérales
c'est vraiment le retour de ces
ambassadeurs respectifs samedi quoi tout
de même ça ça montre un certain progrès
dans les relations
ça veut dire qu'elles se normalisent au
moins sur le plan formel ce qui est
quand même toujours un signe que que
l'on va se parler
désormais et que
je dirais les rapports de force ayant
été établie chacun sait ce qu'il peut et
ce qu'il ne peut pas et qu'à partir de
ce moment là on passe aux choses
sérieuses on repasse aux choses
sérieuses alors ça ouvre une porte on
est loin d'arriver à terme on ouvre des
portes et je pense pas ce qui est
évidemment aussi important de prendre en
compte que la russie ce qui fait la
force de la russie c'est que le monde et
multilatérales multipolaire entre les
deux puissances dont on a parlé
eh bien il ya des puissances émergentes
où des puissances revenante dans le cas
de la russie plus tôt et pour la russie
je pense qu'il est important aussi elle
a cherché l'émergence d'autres
puissances un peu partout dans le monde
je pense que ce que la russie aussi
souhaiterait c'est que les pays
européens deviennent un peu plus
indépendant et autonome pour renforcer
ce multilatéralisme est donné en quelque
sorte aussi à la russie son rôle à jouer
donc on les je dirais les jeux sont
ouverts maintenant et on verra ce qu'il
en a ce qu'il en adviendra mais disons
on est sorti de la période de tension
maximum oui
théo lobry vous vous êtes spécialiste
est des états unis on sait que cette
rencontre était très observée depuis des
les etats unis 1,2 de joe biden et
vladimir poutine elle avait d'ailleurs
été déjà critiqué avant même d'avoir
lieu dans les rangs démocrates
votre opinion vous avez l'impression que
joe biden a fait a fait le job face à
vladimir poutine et que ça sera bien
accueillie du côté des états unis
oui bah je pense qu'il a fait il a fait
ce qu'il fallait et que états unis on
retiendra de lui qu son voyage en europe
s'est bien déroulée et que surtout il a
rétabli ce que je disais tout à l'heure
le leadership américain
et je le répète mais ce sommet c'est
avant tout à un sommet pour l'image et
aussi pour oublier le sommet d'helsinki
ou trump s'était comporté de façon
surprenante disons avec bladi remis avec
vladimir poutine
ce que les américains avaient assez mal
vécue enfin du moins une partie des
américains
il va pozzo di borgo l'attelage poutine
bei den ça laisse présager quoi comme
comme relation ça avait débuté de
manière très sévère on se souvient baid
aid traitant vladimir poutine de tueurs
finalement ça va être circulez ya rien à
voir
ça va plutôt bien se passer à l'avenir
selon vous c'est pour ça que classics et
ces tensions notamment mais je crois que
si vous permettre là vous a fait
référence à l'union soviétique et je
crois c'est la phrase de reagan qui
disait qu'il y avait des grandes
puissances le rss est là et des états
unis
le rapport de force a changé éliminant
le l'arsenal nucléaire ou les deux pays
contrôlent 90% des arsenaux nucléaires
éliminant le prenons le port de fort
simplement otan russie il faut savoir
que le rapport de force
otan russie est pratiquement de 10,1
c'est à dire que l'otan une puissance
qui est-il incontestable à l'égard de la
russie
et ce qui fait que la communication des
européennes communication des américains
ont des styles aussi caresser pas vrai
la russie a des missiles à 15 km de chez
saint pétersbourg qui qu'ils ont vu thi
menace la russie c'est pareil pour
également pour l'heure les cyberattaques
quand vous pensez que la nes a déjà il
ya 15 20 ans écouté tout le monde nous
nos présidents français sont écoutés par
l'ambassade américaine ce qui n'est pas
le cas d'ambassadrice qui écoute les
présidents français
quand vous pensez qu'à les gaffes à la
puissance des américains était
incontestable par rapport à ce qu'est la
russie
et c'est vrai que la communication qui a
d'ailleurs tout ça c'est à dire la
russie agresseurs je crois qu'il est
bien il faut bien prendre conscience que
la russie et à une puissance moyenne
elle a de quoi se défendre mais surtout
que la grande puissance et un états unis
on n'est plus dans l'union soviétique à
la russie je crois qu'il faut bien
prendre qu'on peut tenir compte de ces
changements de rapports de force qui est
important et y est voilà je voulais dire
çà et là jusqu'au alors pour répondre à
votre question je pense que c'est quand
même très positif et que j'espère que
l'état d'esprit qui s'est installée
malgré l'état profond américain malgré
les journalistes américains car est pas
d'en rajouter enfin briller nos juristes
français aussi d'ailleurs européen
malgré cela je pense que ça a été quand
même une journée qui est quand même
fondamental pour le bon état d'esprit de
l'union européenne de la russie de
l'inde de la deûle états unis et du
monde en général
théo lobry c'est un combat perdu
d'avancé
selon vos combats perdus d'avancé
il faut dire espère que ces relations
vont se normaliser effectivement
vis-à-vis des médias russes ça reste
compliqué ce sera très certainement
compliquées effectivement après je n'ai
pas les tenants et les aboutissants et
comment est ce que les équipes de la
maison blanche du président by donne
pourquoi en fait elles ont refusé
l'accréditation peut-être qu'on le saura
un petit peu plus tard par le biais
d'articles ou ou deux journalistes
américains qui donneront quelques
détails mais aussi revenir sur un point
effectivement les médias américains
notamment ceux de la côte est sont pro
démocrates ont envoyé des extraits de la
messe nbc hbo et mais samedi c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus pro démocrates aux
états unis c'est un peu l'équivalent
trop psychose mais les versions
démocrate
mais je trouve que faire la comparaison
entre helsinki et genève est malvenue
donald trump à helsinki fait confiance à
vladimir poutine plutôt qu'à ses agences
de renseignement alors même qu'il a la
main sur ces agences de renseignement on
va imaginer imaginer n'importe quel
autre président européen qui du jour au
lendemain
désavoue c'est ses propres ses propres
soldats entre guillemets on pourrait
même dire comme ça le scandale que ça
peut faire ça aurait fait le même
scandale à peu près partout donc je
pense que les médias américains à
l'époque on pas exagérer la chose donald
trump a paru dans s'être lancé dans ce
sommet d'helsinki être un petit peu une
marionnette alors dans son style
effectivement et c'est quelque chose qui
est très mal passée donc le sommet de
genève aujourd'hui était un sommet les
plus classiques on n'a pas eu
d'extravagance de parts et d'autres
et je pense que le traitement médiatique
entre helsinki et genève n'est pas tout
à fait comparable
le mot de la fin pour vous bruno devrait
ce qu'ils veuillent routine qui parler
voilà deux noms hostilités volonté de
nous comprendre dialogue constructif
c'est clairement ce qu'on retiendra de
de cette journée qui était malgré tout
un pas plutôt important oui je pense que
c'était un pas important alors
maintenant je pense que booking bien
marquer le point parce qu'il a répondu à
toutes les attaques que dont il a été
l'objet lui évidemment la russie il a
montré sa combativité donc le fait que
battant sera pris hier un rapport de
forces est disons diplomatiquement le
rapport de force il a réussi à le
rétablir même si comme cela a été dit le
rapport de force russie otan est très en
défaveur de la russie mais sur le plan
je dirais de l'image sur le plan de la
de la réponse sur les dossiers sensibles
droits de l'homme droit de la presse et
caetera
je pense que finalement poutine a été
assez habile pour qu'on puisse passer
aux choses sérieuses et à dire là où on
peut s'entendre au tantra pas sur ces
questions qui agitent que je viens de
mentionner mais on peut s'entendre sur
les questions de déséquilibres militaire
de diplomatie de multilatéralisme et
c'est donc sur ce plan là je pense que
les choses vont aller de l'avant
rapide petite conclusion peut-être avec
un vous il faut aussi borgo venir
poutine qui a dit que c'était une
discussion franche et directe
soulignons que ce n'était pas une
compétition mais vous savez bien comme
moi on observe toujours s'il ya un
gagnant et un perdant qui s'est le plus
distingué qui ressort le plus avantagé
et gagnant de cette rencontre est de ces
deux conférences de presse selon vous
non moi je crois que c'est la vérité je
crois qu'il ya eu 7 contre cette
rencontre a été un élément de ou en fait
chacun a dit ce qu'ils avaient à dire et
je pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir un
gagnant et un perdant je crois que
c'était très positif et le posant
poutine a été comme il est le président
biden n'oubliez pas que le président
biden a été tout jacques président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat c'était une puissance et son
ordinaire et qu'il avait des très bons
rapports à l'époque avec les dirigeants
soviétiques c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
le coût de ces l'union soviétique qui
connaît la russie et c'est pour ça que
quand il ya eu les premières
escarmouches entre poutine et villages
nous vivons ça va pas durer
parce qu'il connaît très bien ce rapport
de forces sur la vie aujourd'hui
en fait c'est cette signification l'a
bien vu que ça on avait deux présidents
qui avaient envie si vous les deux n'ont
pas de règle épreuve du jour au
lendemain mais d'engager d'état d'esprit
différent dans le rapport merci beaucoup
à tous les trois bons nombres esquive
pozzo di borgo et théo lobry d'avoir été
avec nous